bonsoir eux
je vais essayer de suivre les conseils
dans jane être authentique
je m'appelle pas technip heures je suis
chirurgien plasticien et quand j'écoute
les propos de gauthier que je remercie
pour cette invitation
je vois une politique d'énergie chez
vous c'est vraiment dans ce genre de
réunion qu'on a vraiment le le sentiment
que l'énergie créatrice bouillonne moi
je vais simplement vous raconter une
petite histoire personnelle que j'ai
créé avec mon équipe et qui peut-être
s'intègre dans le cadre de cette
positive énergie parce que j'ai vu dans
ce petit cursus humanitaire beaucoup
d'énergie alors j'ai raté beaucoup de
photos diapositives un peu gore parce
que gauthier m'a envoyé des emails en me
disant tu va plomber l'ambiance
alors j'ai envie dans des plaines photo
mais il y en a quelques-unes que j'ai
gardé parce que je crois que dans un
concept de realpolitik
il faut que vous voyez un petit peu ce
que c'est l'énergie positive et la
chirurgie plastique c'est positif
deuxième attitude que je vais avoir
c'est une attitude très figé comme me
l'a enseigné marianne elle m'a dit tu es
comme un arbre lui les racines et ça m'a
évoqué tout de suite le baobab
j'ai dit hier elle a compris et m'a dit
le silence silence ça doit s'arrêter
et ça ça m'a évoqué aussi le silence en
a fait sa vie en afrique on parle nous
les blancs beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et
souvent aussi l'or c'est beaucoup plus
important
tout ça pour vous dire que je vais vous
rappeler un petit peu ce que c'est de
chirurgie plastique rapidement et si
vous voulez bien je vais vous présenter
une petite mission en afrique alors la
chirurgie plastique
c'est ça
c'est une spécialité formidable bourré
d'énergie qui associe la réparatrice
c'est à dire quand il ya vraiment une
mutilation
quand le corps est abîmé environ
construit non sur la photo numéro une en
deuil à la chirurgie plastique et touche
la forme qui reconstruit la forme
notamment les membres peuvent être
abîmée et puis à l'esthétique
l'esthétique c'est de numéro trois c'est
dans ce cas là une petite rhinoplastie
est anodin qui est souvent caricaturée
dans les médias qui est souvent présenté
comme quelque chose de négatif mais qui
même en afrique à beaucoup d'importance
pour nous la chirurgie plastique c'est
ça c'est à la fois reconstruire
l'esthétique c'est à dire que quand vous
construisez un enfant il ya toujours une
dimension esthétique et c'est cette
dimension esthétique qui peut sauver
l'enfant la chirurgie esthétique est
vraiment thérapeutique imaginer que
certains pays d'afrique où je vais un
enfant qui a une malformation comme ça
va être noyé à la naissance va être
transformé en enfant esclave je veux pas
plomber l'ambiance
mais dans le cadre de l'énergie positive
une intervention d'une heure 300 de cet
enfant et lui redonne la vie pour moi
c'est ça l'énergie positive alors nos
jobs entre autres c'est de partir en
mission humanitaire alan mulally terre
c'est un mot très marketing qui est très
bien qui est parfait pour vendre ce
qu'on fait mais je l'utiliserai plutôt
le terme les chirurgies en situation
précaire parce que quand on fait de la
chirurgie dans cet environnement
l'humanitaire et secondaire quelque part
à ce que l'humanitaire c'est tous les
jours
humanitaire c'est vous c'est vous avec
votre grand mère sur le palier que vous
allez aider l'humanitaire c'est le petit
bassin à son cabinet médical qui va
faire des soins gratuitement il suffit
pas d'aller spécialement en afrique ou
très loin pour être humain au faire de
l'humanitaire
donc moi je parle des chirurgiens
situation précaire alors pourquoi un
chirurgien qui travaillent dans les
beaux quartiers à paris par émission
parce que c'est une continuité propre à
notre boulot notre job c'est d'opérer à
la fois des liftings des reconstructions
à paris que de faire des maladies
tropicales
c'est le même john la télé petit
finalement et les patients sont les
mêmes
mais pourquoi aller si loin à 6 mois
parce que vous vous imaginez que 80% de
la demande en chirurgie notamment
réparatrice se trouve au village en
brousse et 80 % de cette population dans
le monde n'a pas accès ou sap le soin
que vous vous possédez alors comme
beaucoup de rng avec mon ong on a
travaillé dans les grandes capitales
et puis on s'est vite aperçu que les
patients avaient vraiment pas du tout
accès cette santé donc on a on a été
contre tous les principes c'est à dire
qu'on s'est dit ah ben non on va changer
les choses on va aller au village
ordinaire il faut pas il faut travailler
dans une centre bien avec des tas
d'opérations venir et nous on a été
contre toute les dom
on a dix ans j'ai mis toutes les équipes
en immersion c'est l'ironie version en
immersion ça veut dire que on va au plus
proche des malades pour qu'on va plus
proches des malades parce que ils n'ont
pas trois euros pour venir dans les
vivres dont il est dispensé avant donc
il faut aller vraiment au village donc
on utilise tous les moyens
alors au début c'est sympa la première
mission c'est très touristique on prend
des photos
c'est très sympa la pré admission
la deuxième mission sur la pirogue on a
un peu mal aux fesses et la troisième
mission d' un peu plus donc on est au
delà du tourisme chirurgicale c'est
vraiment accès à des endroits on lequel
seul le bateau la pirogue ou aujourd'hui
parfois l'avion nous donne accès
nécessité alors tout shit on a répondu
au concept d'autonomie c'est à dire qu
on a fait nos petites valises on appris
des pdi kate on a fait une au mal on
voyage avec 250 kg de matériel et on va
partout dans le monde aux endroits qui
sont quasiment inaccessibles
une mission en pratique c'est comme ça
très rapidement c'est vous envisagez de
faire une mission dans un endroit parce
que il ya beaucoup de patients opérés
vous avez un petit réseau local eh bien
vous vous déplacez vous y allez vous
consultez ce sont des grosses
consultation très coloré 200 à 300
personnes
on sélectionne les patients un bon bloc
opératoire et à nos pères on opère
généralement 12 heures par jour
c'est tôt le matin et tard le soir et
concrètement on fait des choses
concrètes c'est j'essaye de rester
vraiment sur les conseils d'un dégel je
reste authentique
ne mets pas dans le show et puis pardon
gauthier 30 labiale vous avez un enfant
qui est vendu il faut le réparer
le petit garçon avait classé cas de
brûlures c'est un enfant ne peut pas
travailler qui va de sa vie être un
handicap et la lune heures d'opération
il pour travailler aux champs ils ont
fondé une famille l'affection tropicale
que vous voyez c'est le petit honorés
quand on l'a rencontré vivait par terre
un an après on prend des photos ils sont
pas de bonne qualité mais au village et
je vous foot
et puis le nommage vous en parle pas
c'est vraiment le visage de la pauvreté
si je vous raconte son histoire je vais
plombé l'ambiance
donc nos constatations sur le fleuve
matane et de l'émission sur sur sur la
brousse eh bien on a réfléchi on s'est
dit qu'est ce qu'on a trouvé on l'a
prouvé une demande énorme on avoue
trouver une demande différentes
tout ce que j'ai appris à la fac
monsservin a beaucoup est ce que toutes
les pathologies que j'avais appris ce
correspondait pas aux ce que je trouvais
six mois l'environnement est différent
des blocs opératoires n'existe pas on
nous persuade arnaud persuadé bancs etc
on a trouvé une culture différente et ça
c'était le plus passionnant c'est à dire
qu'on a rencontré les gens qui nous
ressemblent pas et il a fallu s'adapter
et il a fallu s'adapter surtout à la
maladie parce que les maladies sont
différentes et surtout la représentation
de la maladie
c'est à dire que pour nous une fantasia
une malformation ou tumeurs un accident
on explique par par notre médecine
moderne dans ces pays là il ya une autre
connotation qui est vraiment la question
pourquoi c'est à dire que quand ils ont
une tumeur canton les opère d'une
maladie ils comprennent comme vous comme
moi ce qu'on va faire ils comprennent
interventions des suites opératoires
mais vous n'avez pas répondu à la
question
pourquoi j'ai cette maladie quelle est
cette culpabilité et surtout qu'elle est
pour être simple
quel est ce sort qui m'a été jetés et là
on s'aperçoit que nous avec le pse
moderne
on n'est ni bon ni mauvais alors la
médecine extraordinaire mais qui n'est
pas forcément adapté hélas le petit
chirurgien plasticien parisien a pu
s'adapter a dû travailler avec des
guérisseurs et c'est aussi de comprendre
ce que tu es la maladie est aujourd'hui
quand on doit soigner très loin de sa
maison habituée à nos hôpitaux français
il faut prendre la guérison sur deux
parties la partie visible et la partie
invisible la partie visible c'est mon
job je rencontrais je fais des landes
rouge je répare les patients et la
partie invisible sur les tradipraticiens
c'est toute la médecine traditionnelle
alors concrètement et pour finir
qu'est ce que nous proposons dans un
cadre de l'énergie positive nous étions
au début trois et on était tout seul et
on s'est dit bon on va travailler on a
travaillé on a fait ça pendant une
vingtaine d'années on continue et on a
développé des concepts relais concept
c'est un concept d'éco chirurgie est
coincé parce que c'est à la mode parce
que j'aurais pu appeler sa concept
biochirurgie bio ça fait référence au
biotope
c'est à dire faire de la chirurgie par
rapport à l'environnement alors quand
vous êtes dans les chu parisien vous
opérer d'une certaine façon mais le
reste du monde ou ne ressemble pas au ch
parisien il a fallu s'adapter s'adapter
ça veut dire que j'ai créé de la
chirurgie mobile et on est revenu il ya
300 ans
ça faisait quand on était des nomades ce
qui était interdit par l'ordre des
médecins
et aujourd'hui il va falloir que vous
soyez mobile parce que tous les propos
que je vous tiens aujourd'hui vous qui
êtes dans une école business vous sont
appropriés mot pour mot mobilité il va
falloir que vous bougiez il va falloir
que vous adaptiez il va falloir que vous
alliez loué à chercher les choses et
surtout vous adapter à l'environnement
différents qui vous allez rencontrer en
pratique je vous allez prendre un humour
en chine qui dope et peut-être que la
marque yoplait et sera intéressante mais
il va falloir peut-être adapter le
yaourt à l'environnement chimie 2,1
cette le concept est de chirurgie
concept qui nous passionne parce que
comme je vous le disais il a fallu
travailler sur des populations qui ont
des croyances différentes et ses
croyances eux avant ses croyances au
moins été inspiré par le regard de
l'autre trop souvent on a un
ethnocentrisme qui fait qu'on regarde
les autres on prend en photo les petits
africains etc regard de l'autre moi dans
cette expérience que j'ai eues en
humanitaire je me suis intéressé au
regard de l'autre comment l'autre te
regarde parce que la chirurgie ou la
spécialité chirurgicale que l'on va
faire qui est extraordinaire je vous le
redis pour qu'elle soit acceptée alors
qu'elle soit comprise et de
l'interrogation c'est de savoir comment
l'autre voie chirurgie pour qu'il
accepte que tu fais explique lui et je
vous incite à vraiment vous intéresser
au regard de l'autre seront pas toujours
vous à regarder les autres
aujourd'hui pratiquement dans cette
démarche
moi je travaille avec un guérisseur
alors c'est sûr que sur des auspices
plus modernes ou sur des tropiques plus
européenne travaille avec un guérisseur
ça pose un problème c'est sûr que les
guérisseurs des tradipraticiens sont
caricaturés à d'autres sorties métro
mais sa vie c'est celui qui vous vend
les petits prospectus on va faire venir
votre femme l'amour ça c'est les 10% de
charlatans mais la médecine
traditionnelle est une médecine réel
adaptée au pays aujourd'hui quand je
consulte je consulte avec le guérisseur
qui lui va traiter la partie invisible
qui va expliquer aux patients ce que je
fais et croyez moi c'est un gros effort
de notre part de s'adapter à l'autre et
à la médecine de l'autre et d'année
concept c'est l'école c'est le concept
d'école de chirurgie et là aussi je
pense que va falloir revoir notre
enseignement notamment chirurgicale et
nous la france on a une grosse
responsabilité
parce que former les gens la finalité de
toute mission ça va être de former les
gens j'ai créé depuis dix ans un diplôme
harry qui forment et chirurgiens
américains ou étrangers des pays en voie
développement ou les collègues qui
veulent partir mais aujourd'hui j'en
suis arrivé à une finalité où il faut
former les gens sur place
et là aussi c'est très important parce
que dans un cadre de positive énergie il
va falloir inverser les choses et ça
pour moi c'est vraiment beaucoup
d'énergie parce que il faut faire une
formation sur place pour que des
patients pour les gens se forment dans
un environnement et surtout qui se
forment à avec un environnement qui est
propre
alors la positiver dargis pour moi se
résume à cette dernière la positive qui
est l'énergie
l'amour que la donne dans notre école
business vous apprenez de choses
formidables mais vous apprenez beaucoup
à prendre à notre à travailler avec le
business que je ne dis pas mais je vous
conseille de donner donner dos des
données et vous retrouverez le sourire
comme nous trois parce que nous étions
trois dentistes un anesthésiste un
chirurgien à nous trois cette photo
c'est vingt ans de travail en
humanitaire c'est 5000 consultations ces
1500 ans perd et on n'a pas fait grand
chose dans la opéré on a surtout changé
la vie de 1500 maman je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]